let's go next to our caller from the
nine five six
area code who is calling today from 956
hey this is Michael from Texas hey Mike
what's going on um so I was wondering if
you if you know about the specifics of
the of
burnings free college fund well I mean I
reviewed it when he first published it
is there something in particular about
it you wanted to ask about I don't have
it in front of me yeah so so the way it
works for us to write knowledge is it's
a it's essentially a grants to the
states from the federal government where
the federal government offers to pay two
thirds of the tossed of making tuition
free in the state and then the state
gets to opt in to the three college
tuition and I'm wondering if if we will
see Republican states like Texas
obviously who didn't extend Medicaid
under Obama also not extend this free
college absolutely so this is this is
this is how they'll do it
so as you're rightly pointing out we had
Obamacare Obamacare one of the things
that it offered was an opt-in to for
states to expand Medicaid and I believe
with Obamacare the federal government
would pay ninety percent but the detail
is not totally relevant here you saw a
lot of red state governors governor's in
red states Republican governors not do
the opt-in and then the citizens of
those states said Obamacare passed and
nothing improved that's because
Obamacare is bad and of course it's
actually because their governor chose
not to opt in so here's the way they're
going to play it if Bernie Bernie's plan
for college would happen a lot of red
states would not opt in then what they
would do is let a couple years go by and
then they would say look
Bernie's free college plan cost us five
hundred billion dollars and our college
attendance rate has actually gone down
and it's like well hold on a second you
didn't participate in the opt-in and the
reason that your college rate probably
went down is because
people are moving to other states that
did do it in order to go to school and a
lot of Republican voters will fall for
that and then they'll say free college
is terrible and it'll be another one of
these non information cycles that are so
common in politics hello
oh alright thank you okay
all right that was weird thank you for
the call that's my best assessment the
situation as of right now